here's uh what jordan peterson had to
say
about this new sports illustrated
cover-mop i believe her name is yumi new
is that her name
okay and what did he say he goes sorry
not beautiful and no amount of
authoritarian tolerance is going to
change that she's a pretty girl
you know
but she's a little bit of a bigger gal
voluptuous some may say that
you're going with that
go ahead you don't think she's
attractive i think she's
pretty but she's fat she's pretty happy
she's pretty fast
okay
break this down
go ahead your first thing is you want me
to body shame her go ahead i don't want
to get canceled who do you want you want
what's your first impression what's your
first impression um first impression
uh
like just unhealthy i guess i don't know
is there another picture of her i'm so
used to it now
you're used to what like seeing bigger
girls like that you don't see victoria's
secret angels or any of that anymore you
only see girls i think they're like
being toyed by these companies like
they're using them like they're clowns
it's a joke yeah i was going to say
they're trying to like normalize
not being healthy yeah that's not cool i
don't like that but um can i speak on
the door go ahead i know you're a big
fan of jordan peterson aren't you not
too i think that he's like very smart
and he has a lot of like um informative
things to say
but
saying that on twitter like and he has a
huge platform i mean i don't think
that's
necessary to say like you can't say
sorry not beautiful
i mean you can't say it but i think it's
like very rude to say why
i think it's rude because like in his
eyes okay she's not beautiful but in
other people's eyes she could be
beautiful you get what i'm saying like
beauty is not just all the time just a
superficial thing like oh you have to
have the perfect
you're saying beauty is it technically
is go ahead what do you mean by that
there's like the golden ratio so
technically if you have i think it's in
like threes i did a video on this a long
time ago technically everybody can
recognize if somebody has good genes or
not so facial symmetry yeah facial
seminars that's a real it's a real thing
and people think that that's like oh
people can't detect that when meeting
somebody it's like no we can it's
inside of us we can all find out if
somebody has good genes but the way that
he's saying not beautiful he's trying to
promote that that's not
something girls should look up to that's
true i don't know which means he could
be saving lives by saying that yeah like
that's true too i mean i get it but the
way he's going about saying that is not
right i don't think i'm sure he's
definitely setting it up
like he could have said something like
um
i don't necessarily approve of this
because it shows like an unhealthy body
image he can say something like that but
to just go and say like not beautiful on
his platform i think that's not smart on
his part
and again you're a fan of jordan
peterson you're just not a fan of this
comment i am i'm a huge fan of him but i
don't think that was like a thing to say
unless he's like trying to do some like
publicity son it's a magazine you know
it's media peterson doesn't need a
publicity stuff that's true
he has he is such a large following he
has such a large um you know a
passionate fan base there's there's no
real reason to do this with the
exception of the fact that um
it's i mean it generates interest it
generates buzz uh i i recently put a
joke on i didn't even put a picture
attached to it i said i said it there
nothing generates like engagement like
no fat chicks that you put something
like that to that to that effect on
twitter and your your it'll blow up
it'll go viral just because that's that
that's where we're at right now and i
was going to tell you that's uh this is
sort of a sign of the times right now
and i don't mean that in the sense that
it's you know
when we look at the obesity rates right
now in the united
of the american state
is overweight
40 percent of women in the united states
are morbidly obese that is morbidly
obese and so to say to say this is
beautiful whatever it normalizes the
idea that this is this is the norm this
is what you're going to see well
does it say this is beautiful or is she
just on the front of the no but that's
the conversation it's meant to provoke
why is it that a skinny girl has a cover
like that and she's called the slot but
a fat girl does it and she's
inspirational that's a very good point
right there
[Music]